so let's let's dwell on nato for a
moment shall we the events are underway
today and tomorrow uh certainly the u.s
defense secretary suggesting that nato
has grown stronger with the challenge of
what we've seen um and is that do do you
think in a sense a byproduct a
backfiring by-product of of president
putin's um aggression as nato would see
it here
i do think it is uh at least two of the
strategic objectives of uh russia are to
divide and deter nato and divide and
weaken the eu what we've seen is largely
a unified response from nato of course
there'll be nuances in how you approach
this but you would expect that and
really what are the three d's of the
moment with dialogue deterrence
and
um and diplomacy and so they've all been
successful at the moment and that raises
the cost to uh putin of any action i
think it's also significant that the
words of president biden in terms of the
likelihood of an attack at the moment
it's slightly gone down in intelligence
terms if you were to analyze his words
you'd say you'd put it now in the 55 to
75 probability in an attack but like all
these things it's in russia who initiate
and control the timetable not the west
if they're going to invade
well let's pick up on one of your ds
then shall we deterrence come onto
sanctions in just a moment but first of
all in terms of bolstering the eastern
flank of nato already seeing more troops
uh setting off i think from north
carolina do you think we might get
promises from nato that you know more
more bolstering will happen possibly in
the in the southeastern part
yeah
particularly in the south east so really
in 2016 we changed the parameters after
the warsaw summit and went uh from a
posture of reassurance to a posture of
deterrence by denial and that's what led
to the enhanced uh battle groups in
lithuania latvia estonia and poland now
on the southern flank the secure supreme
allied commander europe has talked about
additional battle groups in romania and
bulgaria so that really is deterrence by
denial which we've done there should
russia invade you will go to a different
posture which is
deterrence by punishment and that
includes sanctions
what about this idea of de-escalation
russia again saying that it's removing
tanks for example uh overnight uh some
tank withdrawal um the irish um the
russian ambassador to ireland get it
right uh quoted by the task news agency
has suggested that the russian forces in
the west will be back to normal in three
or four weeks um another saying here of
course is we wait to see if it really
happens but are you getting a sense that
actually when these exercises are over
that indeed might be the case
no i don't think so yet but uh rather
bizarrely it was stalin who said trust
people but check and that checking the
verification by surveillance will tell
you this so really it's the surveillance
flights and the satellite imagery which
will tell you if in uh for space and
time the russians still have a fight
tonight capability there and it's not
really seeing a few tanks in crimea sort
of going from a to b it's really seeing
an off-ramp of combined arms army
capabilities long-range fires or
helicopters returning to the base
further into
russian territory which will give you an
indication because it's not battalion
tactical groups which will be
significant if there's any uh war it
would be those combined arms army
capabilities and really it would be for
me to see capabilities withdrawing from
belarus rather than ukraine because from
my perspective i think the central
gravity the source of all the strength
of the ukrainians is the resistance
around kiev i don't think the russians
would achieve any strategic objectives
just by going into the donbass or the
crimea it would actually reinforce the
fact that ukraine would still be
westward-looking after any invasion and
that's really the dilemma the russians
have which really gives you a sense of
whether they decide to invade they need
a trigger they need local support which
today isn't their unity it doesn't seem
they have that the anticipated military
reaction 45 of ukrainians say that
they'll fight against them and can they
actually have the technical feasibility
at the moment that is that the weather's
against them so at the moment there's a
thing called rappertitsa which is the
mud of spring and so you wouldn't want
to be putin's met man at the moment if
you were trying to decide on an invasion
finally putin needs low economic and
political costs and
can he secure all his strategic
objectives
at those low political and economic
costs i'm not sure he can at the moment
well certainly from what we heard from
joe biden
uh the cost will be absolutely enormous
the consequences for president putin uh
will be far-reaching and long-standing
so let's go on to sanctions then whether
they still have bite um sanctions on
russia since they took crimea in 2014 uh
increased after the sorcery poisonings
and again after accusations of russian
interference in the u.s election the
problem is of course the price of oil
so are they somewhat shielded now by the
impact of western sanctions because of
the very conflict that you might argue
they have started
well the first thing is that geoeconomic
theories were in vogue about 30 years
ago but really people in power are not
accountants they're not bookkeepers they
look at whether they can achieve or
increase their power so that's the sort
of setting within which we are at the
moment now the west and nato actually
telegraphed the sort of
batch of measures that they would take
against them the one i think that russia
would possibly fear is the uh uh cutting
the financial russian banks off from the
international financial system including
the swift but russians will have war
game this to see if they can
deny that happening the second of course
that we would do is there would be
embargoed from u.s technology and the
third one which is the variable again
which we really talked about a bit
earlier is that we would arm
the ukrainians for the war after the war
assuming there is one if if putin cannot
have an early victory you have a war
after the war which raises political and
economic costs to him finally you've got
this difficult one about nordstrom 2 and
i say it's difficult there's been some
fairly poor analysis on this so there's
actually a mutual dependency on the gas
from oil
73
of russia's gas goes to the eu
they don't want to lose that income now
we can we can uh we can sustain not
having russian gas for a number of
months and of course we also will have
been gaining the fact that we might be
able to have supply from somewhere else
but that's a another key variable both
for the west and the east but an eu
stress test in 2014 said that we could
uh outlast for a number of months anyway
uh any problems with gas being turned
off from russia that doesn't mean that
there's not a different issue about the
cost of gas but it's not the supply
which is in the short term an issue and
if we're in the issue of a long term
term war then we've got a different
issue for russia anyway the first thing
we would say is that armies don't fight
wars nations fight wars and what putin
needs to achieve is the dislocation of
both the armed forces of ukraine which i
think he could do in the short term the
dislocation of the political entity of
ukraine i.e needs to go to kiev and put
in a puppet regime and thirdly he needs
to dislocate the ukrainian people those
45 percent who at least have said that
they will sign up to any resistance
against putin now what he's really done
since april last year when we had the
first war scare
is try and uh
impose some psychological pressure on
the ukrainians and actually i think uh
president zielinski has been very good
at making sure that alert fatigue has
not been there in the ukrainian people
but of course putin could sustain this
pressure and have that psychological uh
pressure on the ukrainians and it's that
which often collapses societies in war
as we sort of saw in sort of the fall of
france for example in 1940
just a quick word on uh jaya bolsonaro
the brazilian president obviously
meeting president putin this idea of the
the bric nations brazil russia
india and china and a sense of the the
new world or order
and whether
in a sense president putin is going back
to old alliances in order to counter the
west and and how you see geopolitically
the impact of this long term
well there's only been a west year
politically three times in history 1917
1918 1939 to 1945 and the cold war now
the actions of putin may actually
reinforce reinforce the fact that there
will be a political west in the future
because some of this actions already
have made sure that nato has been
reinvigorated for the future
may reinvigorate the eu and so at the
moment it doesn't look like he's been
that kanye on achieving his strategic
objectives and as we were talking four
years ago really anna uh putin uh has a
weak hand which he's played well but
whether he's played it that well in
2022 as he sort of did over the
scriptural case and all those things
which led up to that with the american
election i'm not quite sure i think he's
kind of losing it but that said he will
outlast all the western politicians when
currently in putin 4.0 putin is going to
be in power unless something goes wrong
until 2036 he has still got a long term
time there to achieve his political
objectives so don't write him off yet
well you say that and there we are yet
another day showing pictures of
president putin meeting a world leader
so in that sense he's got entirely what
he wanted which is global recognition
and a sense of power
i'd actually reverse that and say that
as many of those people have actually
gone to see president zielinski so
zielinski has been uh also empowered by
this the ukrainian people have been
empowered by that and i don't think that
is a reaction that president putin
expected